good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can make new
friends probably that's maybe the
sweetest word to a kid friends as we get
a little older and we have our friends
they become very close to us and and
sometimes they become almost
all-consuming they are everything to us
I can remember as a parent as my
children got to a certain age and where
they look to me for influence I can
remember very well when I saw the
beginning to go to their friends and
that's where their influence began and
that's where their influence began to
increase as a parent that got a little
scary for me because I could I could see
I was having a little less influence
than the friends were having a little
bit more well my parents were very wise
my parents understood that who my
friends were would determine who I was
going to become birds of a feather flock
together and in their wisdom they
decided that they wanted to know my
friends and they wanted to see my
friends so therefore they provided a lot
of wonderful things at her home so we
would have our friends at our house so
that my parents could observe and watch
the kind of kids I ran around with and
what I learned as a kid growing up is
very simple there are some friends that
were positive for me and there were some
friends that were negative for me and my
determination of which friends I was
going to let influence me basically
determined whether I was gonna have a
positive or a negative life fortunately
because of good parental advice and
guidance
I chose good friends which really did
make a difference because you see
friends are wonderful they give us
support they give us strength they're
either though a real asset or real
liability so I would just want to
encourage you choose your friends wisely
you don't need a lot but you need some
good ones
the first tip I want to give you guys
when it comes to making new friends is
having a common interest with someone
there's so many people in this world and
I'm pretty sure you guys walk past
hundreds of people all the time how do
you know that you have something in
common with them how do you know if that
person is gonna be your friend you don't
that's kind of the whole point of life
is not knowing what's gonna happen and
not knowing who you're gonna meet but I
think if you open yourself up to it and
you are showing people that you have a
certain interest that you like there's
gonna be certain people who are very
like-minded like yourself that's gonna
pick up on it don't underestimate the
power of having a sense of common
interest because it really does bring
people together doesn't necessarily mean
you have to have everything in common if
they're speaking to you if they're
making a comment like oh my gosh I love
that song oh my gosh I love your shirt
tell them where you got it I love your
jeans - where did you get that BAM
already right there you have common
interests with that person so what do
you do from there you engage and that's
the next step you're not gonna be able
to make friends if you're not the one
actively engaging with them to ask them
questions I mean if you're actively
engaging with them they're gonna engage
back with you and that's when you can
really make that connection and that's
step number three connect with that
person you can add them on Instagram or
Facebook and that's when you will know
if this is someone that really wants you
in their life or vice versa give them an
email I mean you don't really need to
exchange numbers right away can just be
as simple as hey you have Instagram can
I follow you is that cool I think it's
polite to show that you know you're
asking to follow them
friendship is not just one thing there's
different levels of friendship how do
you know if this person is more than an
acquaintance is when you're constantly
texting them or you're chatting with
them online your video chatting with
them you're sending them links and
messages if you're honestly dialoguing
all the time that's when you know that
hey you know what this person might be a
cool friend accept every invitation true
story I have a good friend her name is
Amy Amy went through a messy divorce and
the process lost a lot of her good
friends and so what she decided when she
was sort of bummed out right she's like
yo I don't have all these friends
anymore
I'm sort of a little bit lonely I'm not
being as social as I'd like to be what
she decided for one year was to accept
every invitation that people offered and
what she found is that she had the best
year of her life by the end of it she
had some friends that she loved that
were incredible that she never would
have met if she stayed isolated and
didn't say yes gentlemen accept
invitations say yes do not be Precious
about who you hang out with in the
beginning okay don't go hang out with
the crackhead on the corner who is gonna
bring your life down if you start
hanging out with them but hang out with
whoever you want be chill about it you
don't have to find this person that
connects with you in every single way
and becomes this best friend for life
immediately some people you'll go out
and watch football with some people
you'll go out shopping with other people
you'll have good intellectual
conversations with but you don't have to
find everything in one person you know
I'd go to a party and I'd come with this
person but I'd end up meeting five more
people that they didn't even know and
one of those five people ended up being
the person I still know today the point
is don't get so picky that you cut
yourself off before you've even started
you need to be understanding we all like
I said have bad days we have bad weeks
we have bad months friendship is going
to be hard especially when you've known
each other for a really long time or
know someone like everyone is raised
differently every family does things
differently I think you know for me I
try to be really forgiving I try to be
the first person to apologize but you
know I try to be understanding
try to see things from other people's
perspectives I'm not perfect
but at the end of the day it really is
up to you I like how deep of friendships
that you want to have with people
because you are going to get invites
with really close friends and you have
to decide do you want this person in
your life or do you not want this person
in your life and it's really up to you
and if you're gonna have like deep
lifelong friendships there's gonna be
rough moments and you have to learn to
forgive and not necessarily forget
because people are not allowed to abuse
you but you do need to learn to forgive
and move on or that person isn't around
and then everyone loses I think that for
most people that they're really having
trouble making friends or have zero
friends at all it's really because of
point number one you're not actually
going out and being around people you
need some ideas for how to do that see
your life right now it's like this this
pattern this habit of just going to work
or going to home or doing doing stuff
that's very isolated and insulating
instead you want to open that up that
means you need to do what you need to go
join some new group join a club join an
organization go hang out with the people
that are at work you know organize a
work event where you're going off out
after work and socializing in some way
to a bar or a club or restaurant or some
some sort of event that you're doing
together you got to do that maybe join
some sort of sports team or sports
league you can go to meetup calm there's
tons of meetup groups that you can
basically find a meetup group on any
topic in the entire world that you want
to and and and join that so you got to
do a little bit of research and figure
out where you can place yourself where
you're literally surrounded by more
people this is probably the biggest
thing because if you do this the other
points they'll tend to autocorrect
right this idea about being shy and fake
well if you're around a lot of people
all the time then this shy and fake
thing it will eventually dissolve
eventually you'll just kind of you know
you'll break through it it'll bust out
of your comfort comfort zone if you're
around a lot of people but if you're
never around a lot of people then some
are going to happen you're gonna remain
shy and fake and if you're always
judgmental about people that - if you're
always around a lot of people then
you're not going to be able to maintain
that judgmental attitude so the reason
you're very judgmental is probably
because you're already very isolated
and living in your own little bubble be
around a lot of people be around a lot
of diverse people and then your judgment
it'll it'll also dissipate because your
mind will open up people will open up
your mind as you're interacting with
them and also if you don't have the time
and energy right now then that too might
change after you go out and join one of
these groups that start to socialize
more because as you're socializing
you're seeing little difficult to
describe the benefits that you get from
friends a lot of the benefits you get
from friends are very subtle and small
maybe your friend will just tell you
about a book that they read that they
really liked or they'll tell you about a
new cool restaurant that's opening or
they'll invite you to go with them on
some some trip next weekend and just
like very simple little things like that
which can lead to actually pretty
extraordinary profound changes in your
life because maybe then you go to to
that restaurant and you meet your dream
spouse there or maybe you go read that
book that they recommended and that
turned out to be a life-changing book
for you so friends are nice because they
open you up to all sorts of new ideas
this is why having diverse friends is
important
don't just be friends with people that
are identical to you you're not getting
you're not getting that
cross-pollination that you will get when
you're interacting with people who are
very different than you I love having
friends that are very very different for
me I learned so much from them to me
those are some of the most rewarding and
interesting friends thank you guys so
much for watching I made this video
because my videographer Jason asked me
to so there's a topic you want me to
cover in the next edition of believe
life leave it in the comments below and
we'll see what we can do it's also
really interesting topic and I'm curious
to hear your thoughts on making new
friends if you have trouble doing it how
you do it and if you've learned anything
from this clip this video and what
you've learned and how that might impact
how you go about your day to day life
I'm really curious to find out and I
think your story could also help inspire
some change in other people as well so
please leave a comment underneath in the
video thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon